[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de face aux territoires une
émission en direct sur tv5 monde mais
également en live en direct sur les
sites de nos partenaires co producteur
ouest france avec ouest france.fr
nicematin.com et groupe nice-matin et
bien sûr franceantilles.fr qui nous
diffuse en léger différé du aux fuseaux
horaires l'invité ce matin c'est valérie
pécresse bonjour non merci d'être avec
nous valérie pécresse vous êtes
présidente de la région ile de france
nul de l'ignorent vous êtes ancien
ministre et vous êtes candidate à
l'investiture des républicains pour
l'élection présidentielle merci d'être
avec nous pour les 40 prochaines minutes
tous réservés dans un instant par les
éditorialistes et patrons de la presse
quotidienne régionale partenaires de
cette émission en norvège
cette nuit dans la ville de ganges berg
au moins cinq morts de blessés par un
homme armé d'un arc vu le déroulement il
est naturel évaluées qu'il s'agit d'une
attaque terroriste selon la police on
n'est pas encore tout à fait sûr en
réalité la question que j'ai à vous
poser ses on se réveille maintenant
souvent avec ce type de 2,2 de
l'assassinât ce type de problématique
sans en être vraiment étonné on a
vraiment changé d'époque
d'abord il faut attendre évidemment la
conversation parce que ça peut être
aussi quelqu'un car avec un arc tout de
même ça peut être quelqu'un qui est qui
qui
qui a fait cela pour des motifs
personnels
mais ce qui est évident pour moi c'est
que la menace terroriste nous allons
devoir apprendre à vivre avec parce que
l'islamisme et le nouveau totalitarisme
du 21e siècle c'est une idéologie qui
infiltrent nos sociétés et qui conduit
un certain nombre de nos compatriotes de
des ressortissants de tous les pays
occidentaux à détester leurs propres
pays à prendre les armes contre lui et
donc il faut s'armer nous aussi contre
ce totalitarisme et il faut prendre des
mesures de prévention et de sanction
très vite quand on décèle des signaux
faibles de radicalisation c'est pour
cela que j'ai proposé un véritable plan
de lutte contre la radicalisation avec
la possibilité y compris d'aller
jusqu'au licenciement ou à la révocation
da on public ou de personnel dans les
sociétés privées qui montrerait des
signes de radicalisation
aleri pécresse vous êtes candidate à
l'investiture des républicains pour
l'élection présidentielle je le disais
il ya un instant et c'est vrai que les
partis qui ont abandonné les primaires
en tout cas pour cette élection
tiennent énormément compte des sondages
est-ce qu'on n'est pas la limite d'un
problème démocratique est ce que
aujourd'hui le phénomène sondagier
zemmour qui est un phénomène sondages et
pour l'instant il n'est même pas
candidat aux présidentielles la manière
dont les sondages tente de départager
jean luc mélenchon
d'anne hidalgo
de yannick jadot
aussi à gauche à droite entre vous
xavier bertrand michel barnier les
autres prétendants à la candidature
les sondages on joue un énorme une
énorme un énorme jeu qui est quasi
pervers aujourd'hui on en vient à ne pas
moins considéré en réalité le vote des
gens est-ce que c'est pas un problème de
démocratie mais vous avez totalement
raison d'ailleurs dans les interviews
que je fais quasiment quotidiennement
plusieurs fois par semaine on ne me
parle on me parle davantage des sondages
de la veille que de mon projet pour la
france je viens de présenter un
programme pour l'éducation à la veille
de la commémoration est dommage à samuel
pâtit je propose un programme dans
lequel je re ba toutes les cartes pour
restaurer l'école parce que nous sommes
devenus une terre d'inégalités sociales
dit mobilité sociale est revenue à
l'école l'école l'école aa oui mais
voyez sur les relevés relevé les
sondages soient devenus au fond le nec
plus ultra dans une démocratie comme la
france c'est une aberration d'autant
plus qu'il se trompe à chaque fois enfin
souvenez-vous des européennes et des
régionales où on nous donnait le front
national gagnant dans une demi-douzaine
de régions donc les sondages se trompent
toujours et ce qui intéresse les
français vraiment c'est qu'est-ce que
tel ou tel candidat va faire pour moi
pour la france je vous dis quand je
parle de onze de l'immigration a
couronné les quand je passe de restaurer
l'école quand je parle de quelle
écologie nous devons défendre parce que
le prochain président la prochaine
présidente devra être un écologiste
sincère mais pas un idéologue
aujourd'hui on est la journée de la
qualité de l'air qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour améliorer qu'il est entré dans
certainement pas bloquer les trains
comme le font aujourd'hui les verts sous
prétexte qu à des lézards des murailles
sur les voies à vous et donc le sujet
c'est comment est ce que on se projette
dans la france dès 2030 eh bien nous
allons attaquer ces sujets là tout de
suite françois-xavier l'offrant à l'acte
en ciel de ouest france nous rejoint sur
ce plateau dans un instant
bonjour françois xavier le franc vous
êtes le rédacteur en chef du plus grand
quotidien régional français le premier
quotidien francophone du monde et vous
avez des questions concernant l'égalité
territoriale beaucoup d'inégalités
bonjour madame pécresse engin alors la
diversité française label diversité
française c'est aussi celle de ces
territoires en métropole et en aidant et
dans le monde avec beaucoup d'inégalités
alors comment lutter contre les
inégalités entre territoires vous pour
la rappeler vous êtes président d'une
grande région ile de france vous êtes
vous souhaitez vous souhaiteriez être
candidate à la présidence de la
république faut-il plus d'état ou
faut-il plus de pouvoirs aux régions
plus de confiance plus de moyens le en
direction des territoires est-ce que
c'est l'état qui peut faire le boulot la
lutte contre les inégalités ou est-ce
que c'est au contraire est-ce que ça
doit venir des territoires qu'en pensez
vous
depuis des années je crois que les
régions sont des vrais réducteur
d'inégalités
pourquoi mais parce que dans une région
vous avez des métropoles des territoires
urbains et vous avez des territoires
ruraux et à l'échelle d'une région on a
la puissance financière pour mieux
répartir la richesse moi je prône le
juste retour vis-à-vis des territoires
ruraux le juste retour ça veut dire que
1 euros d'investissement dans une zone
urbaine doit donner lieu à un euro
d'investissement dans une zone rurale
c'est ce que j'ai pratiqué dans ma
région les français croient peut-être à
tort mais vous vous le savez que ma
région pic urbaine c'est vrai elle l'est
elle est très dense mais j'ai deux
millions d'habitants dont le rural
d'ailleurs christian jacob syndicaliste
agricole gérard larcher vétérinaires
sont tous les deux franciliens donc
effectivement le juste retour mais à
quel niveau on peut le faire certains
diront à haut niveau de l'état ça n'est
pas vrai
trop loin les tailles trop loin et quand
ils s'occupent de la désertification
médicale quand ils s'occupent de
d'opérations coeur de ville en réalité
très souvent s'il est trop loin je donne
un exemple moi dans mon projet il ya le
jumelage des universités avec les villes
moyennes de façon à ce que dans les
départements ruraux j'étais hier dans
l'yonne où on n'a pas de grandes
universités on puisse faire ses
premières années diversité dans son
lycée par internet il ya un appel à
projet qui a été lancé par l'état pour
faire ça en prenant le modèle de ce qui
se faisait en ile-de-france dans ma
région et bien l'appel à projets ces
deux trois lycées par ci par là c'est
pas du tout à la hauteur six universités
a envie je vais à l'université de dijon
aujourd'hui six universités a envie de
faire ça tout seul de rayonner mais il
faut que la région puisse nous donner
les moyens de le faire il faut pas tout
attendre de l'état l'état quand il veut
tout faire il fait tout mal parce qu'il
est trop loin vous avez souvent pointée
d'ailleurs la lourdeur de l'état et on a
parfois l'impression que les régions
avance à une vitesse et l'état à une
autre l'état annonce des investissements
ça met beaucoup de temps à se mettre en
place l'argent mais beaucoup de temps à
arriver alors est-ce que c'est pas
compliqué ce lien entre l'état et les
régions est ce qu'on n'est pas
définitivement dans un une impasse très
française avec un pays très très très
jacobin très centralisé et des
territoires quand il y en a pas vraiment
confiance finalement je suis patriote et
régionaliste je crois aux identités
régionales elles sont extrêmement
puissante et elle donne de la cohésion
parce qu'on se reconnaît dans l'identité
de sa région et en même temps ça nous
permet de nous projeter dans un avenir
commun nous vous avez raison l'autre
jour j'étais en saône-et-loire et on
voit bien que président de la saône et
loire lui il a décidé de rémunérer ses
médecins pour lutter contre la
désertification médicale à
saint-quay-portrieux pareil le maire
décide donc aider ces initiatives
locales qui correspondent à un besoin du
territoire permettre aussi
d'expérimenter de différencier alors je
sais qu'il ya une loi qui en
en préparation une loi qui s'appelle
différenciation décentralisation le 1er
mai c'est mais c'est encore mais c'est
encore une occasion manquée c'est encore
des micros réglages ça et sur la santé
qui est le gros sujet d'inégalités
aujourd'hui entre les territoires il
faudrait là encore que les régions
président les agences régionales de
santé et que les départements et toute
la compétence du social intégralement
quand vous êtes handicapé selon votre
type de handicap et votre âge vous
dépendrez de l'état du département
les français ne s'y retrouve plus et
puis alors je vous dis pas le coup la
bureaucratie c'est valérie pécresse
présidente de la région ile de france
est candidate à l'investiture des
républicains pour l'élection
présidentielle qui est notre invité ce
matin valérie pécresse ouest france est
allé interroger rock fair ok le
président des maires de loire-atlantique
et maire de saint viaud c'est une mère
commune de 2500 habitants ça et il a une
question à vous poser on l'écouté vous
lui répondez
chauveau le géant des mers niveau de
l'art antique mais rosario ma question
est toute simple la commune c'est
l'essence et de la république pourtant
toutes les communes ne sont pas égales
dans les politiques publiques nous le
voyons au niveau des dotations du
maintien des avis public c'est l'argent
des frustrations de l'ascension des
crises à l'instar de celle des gilets
jaunes comment vous une habitude et
politiques urbaines seraient ou crédible
pour les territoires la présidente des
maires ruraux à il a les qualités pour
vous poser cette question passe et ça
revient à ce que je viens d'expliquer
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut qu'à
chaque fois qu'on investit un euro que
l'état investit un euro dans une zone
urbaine il puisse y avoir un juste
retour pour les territoires ruraux et
qui est aussi un euro investi dans un
territoire rural il faut qu'ils même
qualité de service public et
d'infrastructures dans tous les
territoires et il faut pour cela
s'appuyer sur les régions qui seront les
mieux à même de mieux de répartir les
forces là encore je donne un autre
exemple mais les zonages il ya des
zonages et à vous savez par exemple des
zones de revitalisation rurale qui sont
des zonages état mais vous êtes à trois
kilomètres de là zrr vous n'avez plus le
droit aux aides ça c'est idiot parce que
peut-être que le médecin veut
s'installer dans à trois kilomètres
peut-être que l'entreprise installé à
trois kilomètres de la zr1 peut-être que
l'agriculteur d'à côté a besoin d' aide
donc si on commence à sonner au niveau
de l'état on n'y arrivera pas il faut
descendre beaucoup plus bas dans les
territoires alors réellement à
l'intérieur des mêmes territoires il ya
des situations d'inégalité vous parliez
tout à l'heure en introduction de
l'éducation de l'enseignement c'est un
thème qui vous est cher regardons
l'ile-de-france en ile de france si on
regarde le nombre d'enseignants
débutants
et si on regarde le comment dirais-je le
remplacement des ancêtres des
enseignants la question du remplacement
des enseignants on passe du simple au
triple selon qu'on est dans un
territoire dans une zone favoriser de
l'ile-de-france ou selon qu'on est dans
un des parts dans un endroit plutôt
défavorisés avec des problèmes sociaux
importants on a en fait un peu le
sentiment que selon l'endroit où l'on en
est l'état porte une attention plus ou
moins grande c'est peut-être pas le cas
mais en tout cas c'est l'impression que
ça donne comment est-ce qu'on peut
lutter contre ça alors c'est pas sait
pas exactement ce qui se passe l'état
malheureusement n'y est pas pour grand
chose qui ce qui est coupable c'est de
penser que en ayant une gestion uniforme
de l'école on aura l'égalité en fait
l'uniformité créé l'inégalité pourquoi
parce que pour le même salaire enseigner
comme vous le dites dans une zone
favorisés c'est beaucoup plus facile que
d'enseigner à des élèves qui sont plus
perturbateurs qui parle moins bien le
français qui ont plus de difficultés et
sociales et scolaires c'est pas le même
métier et donc moi ce que je propose
c'est de faire totalement différemment
d'abord c'est de régionaliser le
recrutement des professeurs au niveau du
capes pour mettre fin à ce bizutage
institutionnel qui consiste à envoyer
les plus jeunes professeurs dans les
territoires les plus difficiles alors
qu'ils ont le moins d'expérience ça fait
des années qu'on dit qu'on va arrêter ça
et ça fait des années qu'on ne le fait
pas et par ailleurs on envoie des futurs
professeurs ailleurs que dans leur
région de coeur et vous savez
aujourd'hui les professeurs qui sont
mariés ils ont des conjoints des
compagnons qui ne sont pas forcément
mobile donc on dissuade des vocations
c'est qu'on a perdu 30% des vocations de
professeurs en mathématiques par exemple
avec le niveau baisse donc cette crise
des vocations elle est dramatique pour
l'école niveau baisse et l'école c'est
la fabrique de la france donc si on veut
re rendre attractif le métier
d'enseignant il faut régionaliser les
les recrutements de au capes pour que
les professeurs de collèges et lycées
puissent travailler dans la région de
coeur en revanche dans les quartiers les
plus difficiles les territoires ruraux
où il ya le moindre recrutement alors
mais des vrais prime des vrais bonus
indiciaire et des vrais bonus de
carrière avec des professeurs
volontaires et puis on crée aussi des
écoles publiques ce contrat comme ya des
écoles privées ce contrat avec une
totale liberté de recrutement totale
liberté de projets pédagogiques et des
engagements des élèves à respecter et
bien toutes les règles de bon
fonctionnement vous présidez une grande
région où la problématique des
transports est évidemment importante
prend énormément de place il ya un
chantier énorme qui est en cours c'est
le prolongement de la ligne e du rer il
ya quelques jours vous êtes exprimer
avec des mots extrêmement durs vous avez
parlé de scandale d'état ce chantier qui
consiste donc à prolonger la ligne avec
notamment un tunnel entre paris et la
défense dès bord sur plan financier je
crois que on déborde 2,1 milliards 7,1
milliards 7 c'est si je ne me trompe pas
ce que chaque année la région ile de
france mais dans les transports à peu
près vous avez parlé de scandale d'état
qu'est ce qui se passe pourquoi
c'est pas possible aujourd'hui que la
sncf grandes entreprises en monopole
prenne un chantier et nous disent il va
coûter 3 milliards et demi et arrivent
ensuite en me disant non il va coûter 5
milliards et demi ou cinq milliards deux
agents qu'il est presque unique au monde
on peut le dire c'est un chantier de
haut en ile de france nous avons
beaucoup de chantiers qui sont très de
trait et l'option aussi le grand paris
express ont aussi la liaison directe
avec charles de gaulle qui sont des
liaisons très important et puis dans la
france on aura des très grosses liaison
aussi je sais que présent la république
veut lancer relancer les tgv c'est une
bonne idée donc il y aura des grands
chantiers à mener partout en france si
la sncf dérape on ne pourra pas aller
mener le chantier holtz et pas seulement
chantier de leurs heures c'est la
desserte de la normandie parce que si on
fait ce rer jusqu'à mantes la jolie
alors les trains normands pourront
arriver directement parce qu'on va le
dta scandale des scandales état parce
que l'état est actionnaire l'état est
actionnaire à les laisser dériver cette
affaire il il dit aujourd'hui qu'il est
aussi surpris que l'arrêt les financeurs
les départements qui sont financeurs si
l'état est pris par surprise par un
grand opérateur public c'est un scandale
d'état il faut faire un audit un audit
d'ingénierie de sncf réseau parce que ce
qui arrive aujourd'hui à l'ile-de-france
et à la normandie par ricochet peut
arriver aujourd'hui lorsqu'il y aura des
chantiers de tgv je pense par exemple au
bord de toulouse qui est tellement
attendu mais une fois de plus on voit
bien qu'entre les les territoires et
l'état entre les régions et l'état c'est
compliqué c'est toujours compliqué
surtout sur des grands chantiers comme
si tu voulais moi j'entends le président
de la république allait faire un très
grand show pour dire france 2030 on va
faire des grands projets et tous les
grands projets industriels ont du retard
j'étais dans la manche à flamanville
pour visiter le chantier de rush de le p
r nucléaire oui j'ai vu que depuis que
nous nous y intéressions nucléaire nous
l'opposition président de la république
qui voulait fermer 14 centrale a décidé
finalement que le nucléaire avait un
avenir je suis allé à flamanville 12 ans
de retard sur le chantier pour quoi on a
une hyper bureaucratie on a des recours
on a des bâtons dans les roues qui sont
mis à tous les entrepreneurs de france
et ça il va falloir débureaucratiser
c'est mon projet la ville morte parmi
les projets auxquels vous êtes très
attentifs et les universités de la 14
ans une loi a été votée qui porte votre
nom face et la loi sur l'autonomie des
universités
aujourd'hui un centre d'université ont
des ont des problèmes financiers
aujourd'hui on guette l'arrivée des
universités françaises dans les
classements mondiaux et ça met du temps
je mets saclay évidemment deux côtés
quelqu'un qui est un cas un peu à part
est ce qu'il faudrait une deuxième une
deuxième loi de quoi aujourd'hui les
universités françaises c'est important
pour les territoires de quoi ont-elles
besoin je suis persuadé qu'il faut une
étape de l'autonomie et j'en ai parlé
avec les présidents d'universités il ya
quelques jours il faut une étable de de
l'autonomie parce que on leur a donné
des pouvoirs mais qu'à moitié ce avec
françois hollande est un peu revenu sur
la loi autonomie pour diminuer un peu
l'autonomie et puis vous savez c'est pas
facile de fusionner des universités dans
les territoires or ce qui donne de la
puissance à l'université c'est de se
rassembler ses forces c'est l'université
de lorraine qui a fusionné ancien metz
ces universités strasbourg qui a
fusionné l'université de grenoble et
fusionner si on n'arrive pas à créer une
vraie puissance une vraie puissance
qu'on n'arrive pas à voir des
laboratoires au niveau monde yann donc
il faut continuer cette politique cette
stratégie de d'excellence pour les
universités avec des spécialisations
territoriale je le répète c'est très
important d'en créer une université à la
fois au plan international mais aussi
dans les forces économiques de son
territoire valérie pécresse notre invité
aujourd'hui d'en face aux territoires
sur tv5 monde le dessinateur chaunu qui
est un collaborateur régulier de ouest
france à une question à vous poser sous
forme de dessin il s'agit il évoque le
drame du 16 octobre 2020 qui a vu
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit vous en
parliez tout à l'heure à
conflans-sainte-honorine dans les
yvelines au collège poids de losne on
regarde en écoute jolie madame la
présidente je ne vous parlerai ni de lui
ni des autres mais de celui qui fut
assassiné il y a un an dans des
conditions épouvantables victime du
mensonge de la calomnie
de la lâcheté et pour finir de la
barbarie je veux parler bien sûr de
samuel patty est la question que je pose
c'est face aux bouleversements
qui traversent le monde de l'éducation
comment faire pour que
notre république et ses institutions
ne se voilent plus la face
je les dis face à l'entrisme islamistes
il faut des mesures très fortes et c'est
vrai que l'éducation nationale
malheureusement est soumise à ce qu'on
appelle le pas de vagues pas de vagues
et si vous regardez d'ailleurs les
statistiques qui sont donnés chaque
année par jean michel blanquer sur les
actes les signaux faibles de
radicalisation les attentes à la laïcité
dans les établissements là où il ya le
plus de communautarisme c'est la cale
moins de signalements et ça c'est très
inquiétant parce que ça veut dire que il
ya une omerta ya une loi du silence dans
certains établissements les professeurs
ont renoncé à enseigner la shoah ils ont
renoncé à faire des cours d'éducation
sexuelle donc il faut absolument que
l'on puisse avoir des signalements n'ont
pas seulement au ministère de
l'éducation nationale notamment quand un
prof est menacée ou se sent en danger
mais à une cellule de signalements
spécifique du ministère de l'intérieur
et de la justice pour qu' il n'y ait
plus jamais de samuel pâtit et pour que
les professeurs n'aille pas avec la
boule au ventre enseigner mais il ya
d'autres phénomènes de violence dans les
écoles vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé
il ya quelques jours à combs la ville il
faut aussi qu'il y ait des sanctions
exemplaires à chaque fois qu une figure
d'autorité dans notre pays tu agressés
que ce soit un maire un professeur un
médecin ou des forces de l'ordre ou un
pompier et pécresse sans surprise pour
vous maintenant nous avons été
interrogés edith cresson en fin de
première ministre de françois mitterrand
1991 qui a été donc la seule femme
premier ministre en france elle a
quelque chose à vous dire on écoute
je lui souhaite beaucoup de courage sa
cale en a je lui souhaite de continuer
de la façon dont elle s'y prend pour
gouverner la région ile de france c'est
quand même la première la plus riche des
plus importantes de france la manière
dont elle s'éprend est remarquable et
aussi sûrs que dans d'autres fonctions
elle serait remarquable si
c'est vrai que c'est très difficile en
france pour une femme il ya cette espèce
de réticences mais ce simple fait que
vous posez la question
je ne comprends pas parce que dans les
autres pays c'est pas du tout comme ça
donc madame thatcher a été élu au poste
qu'elle a occupé dans le premier
ministre ce qui correspond même chose eh
bien
il n'y a pas eu de questions parce que
c'est une femme n'ont jamais posé de
questions il ya eu avant moi une femme
premier ministre portugais dont il porte
les pays du nord aussi dans les pays du
sud ils sont plus évolués qu'en france
et de la crds et son soutien à valérie
pécresse mais on a travaillé ensemble on
a fait un très beau projet quand j'ai
été élue elle est venue me voir et
décret sont immédiatement elle m'a dit
les écoles de la deuxième chance sont en
faillite c'était son bébé les écoles la
deuxième chose et je me suis aperçu que
effectivement les régions avaient la
compétence pour le décrochage scolaire
mais que l'éducation nationale ne
donnait pas les fichiers des élèves dont
on finance les écoles de la deuxième
chance vide et donc j'ai exigé de najat
vallaud belkacem qui a refusé de me les
donner de jean-michel bancaire qui
finalement les a donnés les fichier des
décrocheurs et ça cette lutte contre le
décrochage en ferait le fil rouge de ma
candidature à la présidentielle je veux
que chaque enfant de france et sa chance
à ceux des femmes en politique madame
pécresse 80% des maires des communes
françaises sont des hommes il ya encore
du boulot
et vous savez c'est très compliqué
d'abord c'est un monde extrêmement
violent la politique et puis c'est très
compliqué de concilier vie familiale vie
professionnelle et engagement politique
vous avez ressenti les meilleurs même
chose que ce qui est dit cresson a
ressenti quand elle parle de son
expérience à matignon cette violence est
ce que c'est des choses que vous vivez
vous avez vécu ce que je crois c'est que
les français sont beaucoup plus ouverts
sur la question des femmes en politique
que la classe politique elle-même c'est
la classe politique qui veut bloquer les
femmes au pouvoir c'est voilà c'est cet
entre soi le masculin mais ce que je
crois aussi vous voyez je vous ai pas
les écoles la deuxième chanson on
m'avait coupé mais c'est important de
montrer ça sert à quoi d'avoir des
femmes en politique à faire et fayer
nous on n'est pas dans le verbe on n'est
pas en train de dire zéro enfants
laissés sur la route nous on prend le
fichier des décrocheurs et on s'occupe
personnellement de les remettre dans ce
monde a compris qu'elle vous soutienne
sa ouvertement
ah oui je suis un peu surprise mais en
même temps je suis très heureuse parce
que ça montre que j'arrive à rassembler
vous savez j'ai été élu dans ma région
j'ai été soutenue de dupont aignan
jusqu'à manuel valls et même mon
prédécesseur et pourtant ça n'avait pas
été une lune de miel entre nous et paul
huchon jean paul huchon a dit il faut
soutenir valérie pécresse qu'elle a fait
du bon boulot donc je crois que les
français ont besoin de ça aussi et il ya
beaucoup d'abstention les français ont
besoin de tant de personnalités qui font
le boulot là une de ouest france
françois xavier le franc aujourd'hui
rapidement consacrés aux entreprises
confrontées aux risques des
cyberattaques elles doivent se prémunir
et c'est donc le sujet que l'on évoque
aujourd'hui dans ouest france avec
notamment question des assurances merci
françois camel offrant rédacteur en chef
de ouest france dans un instant et bien
patrice carmouze qui représentait les 78
les yvelines dans cette émission
[Applaudissements]
bonjour patrice carmouze ou représentés
les jo 18 la chaîne des yvelines vous
connaissez bien valérie pécresse elle
est l'ancienne députée des yvelines ont
pas venir du lourd avec vous dans un
instant à ces questions qui nous
préoccupent mais tout de suite cyril
gautier qui est le directeur des
rédactions de france antique est un
partenaire de cette émission également
france antilles à une question à vous
poser mon écoute bonjour valérie
pécresse vous présidez la région qui
accueille le plus antillo guyanais dans
l'hexagone quels sont vos liens avec eux
quels sont vos liens avec nos
territoires est par ailleurs dans le
cadre de votre candidature quel serait
pour vous la mesure phare en faveur des
outre mer
là pour moi évidemment les outre-mer
c'est la france d'ailleurs là
aujourd'hui on nous parle des antilles
mais j'ai une pensée particulière pour
la nouvelle qualité ne surent qui va se
prononcer pour rester ou pas française
et moi je veux dire tout mon attachement
à la nouvelle calédonie j'aimerais
entendre le président de la république
redire son attachement la nouvelle
calédonie parce que même si l'état doit
être neutre dans l'organisation du
référendum néo calédonien bien
évidemment la france sans la nouvelle
calédonie c'est plus tout à fait la même
france alors pour revenir sur les
antilles je crois les antilles et guyane
et 2
les antilles la guyane nous sommes
l'ile-de-france ce qu'on appelle le
sixième d'hommes c'est à dire que nous
sommes la terre d'accueil des
ultramarins qui sont souvent très
souvent sur les emplois de première
ligne c'est pour cela que moi je
souhaite et je défends depuis toujours
la continuité territoriale la continuité
territoriale c'est de dire que même si
on est loin ici on est dans une île
lointaine eh bien on doit avoir un vrai
sentiment d'être en continuité avec la
métropole alors ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire par exemple que les produits
locaux la banane antillaise dans les
cantines francilienne à les considérer
comme un produit local par opposition à
la banane dominicaine ça veut dire que
les antilles très concret tous les
antillais qui n'ont pas qu'ils sont
démunis qui n'ont pas de quoi payer un
billet d'avion pour aller retourner
faire le deuil d'un des membres de leur
famille on finance des billets deuil
pour ces personnes très défavorisé donc
on fait vraiment une continuité
territoriale on accueille les étudiants
on l'a accueilli sportif on accueille
les les jeunes donc on a vraiment la
volonté de les startups aussi des
antilles en ile-de-france avec des
partenariats tout à fait inédit signé
avec la guyane la guadeloupe et la
martinique et quand le coc vide a frappé
les antilles l'île de france est
mobilisée pour envoyer des respirateurs
pour envoyer des moniteurs pour ouvrir
des dizaines de lits de réanimation
supplémentaire parce que c'est c'est ce
point qui existe entre les antilles de
france avant de revenir aux questions de
sécurité d'immigration avec patrice
carmouze de tv 78 denis carot de nice
matin le directeur des rédactions du
groupe qui sera une question à vous
poser ou écoute valérie pécresse bonjour
la france est le pays dans lequel
l'origine sociale a le plus d'influencé
sur les résultats scolaires en clair
l'ascenseur social est en panne dès
l'école
comment peut-on faire pour améliorer le
niveau de l'enseignement et réduire les
inégalités sociales grâce à l'école tout
à l'heure vous avez parlé des
universités là il s'agit de l'école il
faut remettre les fondamentaux au coeur
de l'école on ne peut pas avoir au jour
née d'appel à la défense
pratiquement 20 % 20 % d'une classe
d'âge qui a des difficultés de lecture
ce n'est pas possible et nous le plus
grand pays des mathématiques ne pouvons
pas être aujourd'hui
dernier en europe pour l'apprentissage
des mathématiques ça n'est pas possible
tout le pays devrait se lever il devrait
y avoir un sursaut national pour
refonder notre école alors comment on va
faire et bien si je suis élu on remettra
les fondamentaux corps du primaire ça
veut dire deux heures de français de
plus une heure de match de plus 50% de
français 25 % made pendant tout le
primaire pour lire écrire compter c'est
la base et un examen d'entrée en sixième
si on repère des jeunes qui ont
évidemment mettra tous les moyens en cm2
pour qu'ils ont réussi cet examen mais
ceux qui n'y arriveront pas ils
rentreront dans des sixièmes de
consolidation dans lesquels hauts lieux
leur matt six ou sept matières et de les
engager dans une dans une logique dans
une spirale de décrochage on leur fera
reprendre pied et on assurera leur
bagage fondamental et je recruterai une
réserve nationale éducative avec des
professeurs retraités que je rémunère
est et le primaire mais au collège au
lycée pour venir faire du soutien
scolaire gratuit parce que toutes les
familles doivent être aidés aujourd'hui
on est dans une sélection par l'argent
qui a les moyens de se payer des petits
cours donc aujourd'hui nous devons
mettre les inégalités scolaires au coeur
notre projet c'est ça un programme
gaulliste social merci patrice carmouze
tv 78 vous en êtes le directeur de la
rédaction oui j'avais peut-être une
question politique quand même pot pour
commencer quand vous voyez les
atermoiements les difficultés de votre
camp a désigné son candidat eu les
premières mains noyer roll congrès 4
décembre comme si on découvrait que il
ya une élection présidentielle en 2022
est ce que vous n'avez pas parfois le
sentiment d'appartenir au clan de ce
qu'on appelle la droite la plus bête du
monde bah vous savez moi j'étais
favorable à une primaire ouverte break
mais depuis lundi je suis extrêmement
soulagé parce que tous les candidats ont
accepté la même règle du jeu et je le
dis d'ailleurs à tous ceux qui nous
écoutent il faut adhérer pour désigner
le candidat de la droite jusqu'au 15
novembre tout le monde peut adhérer pour
voter mais voilà j'ai le sentiment que
le choix de l'unité que j'ai fait depuis
le début le choix de jouer collectif de
respecter les règles de 2,2 me fier aux
choix des militants et bien ce choix
maintenant il est partagé dont j'en suis
très soulagé et je sais qu'on va gagner
parce que les idées de la droite sont
les bonnes pour le pays ce soit
l'autorité que ce soit la liberté ce
soit la dignité que les français
demandent dignité par le travail ces
idées là elles sont celles de là alors
allez justement par dont les idées de la
droite
ont offert beaucoup quand même de
proposition vous que vos concurrents
proposent par exemple référendum sur
l'immigration dont on ne sait pas s'ils
sont les goûts pas mais enfin qui
reprennent en gros des propositions de
marine le pen ou d'eric zemmour vous
même vous aviez proposé la réactivation
de la notion d'intelligence avec
l'ennemi pour pouvoir impressionner des
fichiers s avant qu'ils ne commettent
des actes est ce que est ce que c'est la
droite républicaine ça est-ce que est-ce
que c'est pas une course à l'échalote à
la proposition pour aller de plus en
plus parce que vous êtes embêté par la
position des zemmour de ou de l'open
mais tout au contraire moi mes
propositions elles sont dans le comment
va faire tout ce qu'ils vous disent
immigration zéro c'est impossible mais
c'est absolument impossible on n'y
arrivera jamais et par ailleurs si votre
fils épouse une jeune femme d'origine
étrangère vous aurez envie de la faire
venir en france ou si un agriculteur a
besoin de main d'oeuvre il aura besoin
de main d'oeuvre peut-être étrangères et
de la faire venir donc ça immigration
zéro on n'y arrivera jamais ceux qui le
disent montre moi ce que j'ai fait j'ai
fait une loi constitutionnelle je les
présenter aux français cette loi
instaure un système de quotas
migratoires quotas migratoires pour
l'immigration familiale pour le
regroupement familial pour les étudiants
et aussi pour l'immigration travail avec
cette loi on fixe un principe donnant
donnant pour les pays d'origine oui à
des visas mais à ce moment là s'il ya un
clandestin de votre pays vous donnez le
laissez-passer pour qu'ils rentrent donc
une règle du jeu par ailleurs il faut
qu'on parle le français pour avoir un
titre de séjour donc comme les allemands
je demande un examen de français
obligatoires
aujourd'hui on le fait à la latine vous
savez bien on met des heures
d'apprentissage de français puis il faut
dire qu'on est allé au cours donc
obligatoire si là encore votre enfant
soit aller étudier à l'étranger il doit
passer un examen obligatoire pour
montrer qui c'est s'intégrer et puis les
prestations sociales cinq ans de
résidence régulière en france pour
toucher les prestations sociales parce
que quand on vient en france c'est pour
s'intégrer pour travailler pour apporter
quelque chose à notre pays pas pour
toucher des allocations donc moi j'ai
fait la loi qui pensaient dessous vous
voilà mais ma loi c'est courageux c'est
faisable c'est le système canadien c'est
le système américain les salaires
doivent le week end et c'est ça la loire
et la droite républicaine c'est une
droite qui fait et pas une droite de
l'imprécation et puis des slogans
dernière question pas serment non mais
c'est très malheureux alors on a dit on
a le sens de 2,2 d'écouté alexis gillick
est un étudiant de troisième année de
journalisme à nice la dette qui pèse sur
les générations futures c'est quelque
chose d'important l'écoutent
valérie pécresse bonsoir merci de
répondre à ma question
2735 milliards c'est aujourd'hui le
montant de la dette française d'autant
qu'aux jeunes en tant qu'étudiant je me
pose la question suivante dans votre
plan pour la france dans votre projet
comment comptez vous régler ce problème
de la dette comptez vous augmentez les
impôts faire poser finalement cette
charge sur les générations à venir
comment comptez vous régler ce problème
la jeune étudiant a tout à fait raison
et emmanuel macron alexis emmanuel
macron un tram et la caisse il est en ce
moment en train d'inventer le
clientélisme présidentielle avant
l'élection on en est à 1 milliard ou 2
ou 3 30 par semaine il me serait arrivé
l'économie française pendant la crise
bah si vous regardez le rapport du
conseil d'analysé économique il vous
dira que nous sommes 26e pays sur 38 de
l' ocde dans la gestion de la crise qu
vite ça veut dire que ça nous a coûté
beaucoup plus cher que partout ailleurs
ça personne ne le dit parce qu'on est en
france et que l'argent magique on veut y
croire alors comment je ferais et bien
moi je vais faire la réforme de l'état
la réforme de l'état la réforme des
retraites réforme de l'assurance-chômage
toutes les réformes dont la droite a
rêvé qu'elle n'a pas fait alors vous
allez dire pourquoi moeurs et bien parce
qu'elle dans ma région j'ai fait deux
milliards d'euros d'économies donc j'ai
baissé les dépannages exemple de ce que
vous ferez wing la france j'ai fait de
la politique par la preuve à les
regarder ce qu'on fait mais là
concurrent à droite ils n'ont pas gérer
aussi bien que moi et ses économies je
les réinvestir est éduqué protéger
soigner mes trois priorités pour la
sphère publique merci la une de
nice-matin compte regarder rapidement
puisque nice matin est partenaire de
cette émission vous la voyez
actuellement voilà c'est la politique
locale voilà pourquoi il raille macron
c'est christian estrosi mais il a tort
est-ce que des solutions sont à droite
et pas dans le en même temps qui n'est
qu'à nîmes l'isthme les bécasses merci
patrice car vous merci on passe à la
dernière séquence de cette émission la
partie internationale sylvia garcia de
télé cinq mondes nous rejoint sur ce
plateau dans un instant
[Applaudissements]
alors valérie pécresse votre expérience
en matière de politique étrangère
questionne on se demande si la
présidente de l'île de france s'y
connaît en politique étrangère alors
qu'elle veut devenir présidente de la
république l'intéressé est ce que ce
manque d'expérience ce manque de
visibilité sur l'international ce n'est
pas un souci quand on veut diriger la
sixième puissance mondiale mais d'abord
vous ne connaissez sans doute pas mon
histoire vous ne savez sans doute pas
que je suis anglophone que j'ai été
russophone que j'ai allaité le jour le
japonais alors laissez les langues
difficile qui s'oublie avec le temps
mais c'était la même politique
internationale là dessus on vous sert ne
m'en bien en tant que ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur j'ai négocié
l'arrivée de la fusée soyouz en guyane
j'ai réussi à faire naître un consensus
que vous avez en sciences sociales dans
la lma dans le dans le pays de galles
déficit que vous pouvez avoir par
exemple pas face au président de la
république bien évidemment qui a exercé
pendant cinq ans vous avez le président
de la république avant d'être présent la
république était banquier d'affaires ça
donne pas une expérience internationale
sauf si on considère que faire des deals
financiers à new york ça donne une
compétence universelle je pense que en
tant que ministre là par exemple une
autre exemple j'ai été négocié
le giec de la biodiversité
je suis allé jusqu à kuala lumpur pour
plaider pour concrets face à la sixième
extinction des espèces injecte de la
biodiversité donc que ce soit en matière
écologique je vous ai parlé de la
coopération renforcée j'ai convaincu
tous les pays européens de travailler
ensemble sur la recherche sur alzheimer
donc sur tous ces sujets là il me semble
que j'ai montré une forme de compétences
et par ailleurs c'est par la présidence
de la région ile de france je travaille
en partenariat très étroit avec toute la
francophonie notamment les pays
d'afrique avec lesquels je suis en par
les pays d'afrique justement nouveau
sommet afrique france la semaine
dernière avec une société civile des
jeunes qui ont eu et c'est ce qu'ils ont
affir me l'ont déjà heureux définit la
relation entre leurs pays en afrique et
la france dans votre projet présidentiel
quelle place tient l'afrique l'afrique
et l'europe ont un destin lee et donc
moi je fais partie de ceux qui regrette
infiniment que la france n'est pas plus
d'ambition en afrique que nous n'ayons
pas des partenariats plus étroits avec
l'afrique au niveau au niveau de ma
région quand je suis arrivé j'étais
effaré de me rendre compte que malgré
les liens et la diaspora africaine très
grande qu'il y avait en ile de france
nous n'avions aucun contrat de
partenariat signé avec le maroc mais
avec la tunisie gnac algérie ni même
avec l'afrique subsaharienne donc j'ai
commencé à tisser tous ces réseaux
notamment partant de ce qui nous unit la
francophonie qui est notre premier lien
et je crois que vraiment le plan
marshall pour l'afrique le plan marshall
européen pour l'afrique est une absolue
priorité pour moi nous devons aider au
développement de l'afrique l'afrique
d'en garder sa jeunesse cela-dit les
ailes a dit au sommet avec la présidente
les aides ont baissé dans la région
d'och les aides sont fallait peut-être
pas la solution abandons à daraya et par
ailleurs ces jolies dames c est qu on a
vu devant des partenariats pas de l'aide
c'est mais c'est complètement exacte
j'ai supprimé les aides j'allais dire
qu'ils n'arrivaient jamais c'est à dire
des za du tissu associatif qui n'avait
pas vraiment beaucoup de résultats et
j'ai transformé sa part du partenariat
du vrai partenariat c'est à dire de
l'aide technique de l'apport de
compétences et donc maintenant on fait
des partenariats gagnant gagnant par
exemple pour faire l'éclairage d'une
ville par exemple pour lutter contre la
pollution de l'air pour les transports
donc on fait on fait des vrais projets
maintenant si vous avez lu présidente
dernière question quel est votre
première décision en matière de
politique internationale
ma première décision ce sera de prendre
la présidence de l'union européenne
puisque vous savez le 24 avril le
président qui sera ou la présidente qui
sera élu ça s'appelle viendra non et on
se fait d'aller et d'aller voir nos nos
comptes nos confrères mes confrères
président des grands pays de l'union
pour leur parler de tout ce que je veux
pour changer l'europe parce que je veux
une europe qui protège vraiment jouer en
europe avec une autonomie stratégique
je veux une europe qui deviennent un
pilier dans l'otan je veux que l'europe
nous protège et je vais aussi une
préférence européenne avec la
réciprocité c'est pas normal que nous
laissions l'europe ouverte à tous les
vents du libre échange alors même que
les pays avec lesquels nous faisons du
commerce ne nous respectent pas et ne
voient pas leurs portes valérie pécresse
c'est ce que les militants de l air
voudrais savoir sans doute est ce que
vous prenez l'engagement de ne jamais
être la première ministre d'emmanuel
macron mais cette question est très est
très étrange
emmanuel macron a envoyé contre moi aux
régionales cinq ministres cinq ministres
en marche c'est donc que je suis pour
lui une adversaire très redoutable il a
été aussi unanime aux cibles de
nouvelles je vais vous expliquer je suis
une adversaire très redoutable parce que
parce que justement je porte une droite
qui peut s'élargir au centre et que
comme l'a très bien dit nicolas sarkozy
et ça les militants le savent quand on
s'élargit on gagne quand on se rétrécit
on perd et c'est ça qui fait peur
emmanuel macron donc je suis dans
l'opposition il ya un fossé qui le
sépare des manuels macron à la fois sur
la gestion économique je vous ai parlé
de sa façon de dépenser l'argent des
générations futures de guest de
dilapider l'argent des générations
futures mais surtout sur le régalien sur
l'autorité moi je veux un pays dans
lequel l'ordre et respectez donc dans
lequel l'on grandit à se respecter notre
travail régime j'ai même pas à le
prendre cet engagement il est inscrit
dans ma fidélité à mes valeurs et à mes
convictions depuis cinq ans vous savez
ceux qui ont voulu rejoindre macro ont
pu le faire depuis cinq ans et il aurait
été sûrement très heureux de pouvoir
épingler à son tableau de chasse la
présidente de l'ile-de-france non je
suis fidèle à mes convictions et je le
resterai merci d'avoir été notre invité
pendant 40 minutes valérie pécresse donc
ancien ministre candidate à l'élection
présidentielle à l'investiture des
républicains et présidente de la région
ile de france merci merci beaucoup
sylvain garcia la semaine prochaine nous
recevons elisabeth bord de la ministre
du travail qui sera en direct sur ce
plateau pour face aux territoires merci
à tous bonne journée les problèmes
continuent sur tv5 monde
[Musique]